the process gets started chris with the
cincinnati bengals on the clock look i
still can't completely and totally rule
out stephen ross taking over the
dolphins draft room and making the
bengals an offer they can't and won't
refuse but it looks like it's going to
be joe burrow to the cincinnati bengals
with the first overall pick in the draft
do you see any scenario where that does
not happen
no i do not you know i don't you know
first off i mean you know joe burrow
like i've told you mike when we talked
about quarterbacks it's almost a
flawless film study i mean he's so
talented and for a national football
championship team okay their path
protection stunk at lsu i mean you watch
joe burrow on film and you just go hey
he's under duress every play every other
play and he just makes so many freaking
plays within the pocket not only
scrambling but just moving people around
him making big time throws mike and the
one thing i've consistently heard you
know from around the nfl
people are they're they're
totally impressed with joe burrow the
man the leader you know the guy he has
the charisma everything about it so uh i
i don't see there's any way and i've
been told by a few people in the know
already that the bengals are just
smitten with what they've learned and
with what they've gotten to know about
joe burrow here through this process
i'm gonna be talking to him this
afternoon and one of the things i want
to really delve into how he handled that
period of time at ohio state when he was
passed over for dwayne haskins the
decision to transfer he graduated from
ohio state in three years my goodness
that's what allowed him to play right
away at lsu in 2018 and not have to take
a year off but you know
we we see the finished product we see
the guy who's ready to be the number one
overall pick in the draft and we just
assume it was easy for him every step of
the way it was not easy for joe burrow
so i want to hear more about that story
about how he dealt with the adversity at
ohio state and how he turned that into
the motivation that has propelled him to
where he is also he reached out to
peyton manning which shows that he's
smart he's doing his homework he's
getting advice he's getting information
he's not he's not trapped by that
arrogance of youth that makes you think
you have all the answers and no one else
who's been there before can help you
through it and peyton manning had this
to say about joe burrow reaching out i
told him joe when you're the first pick
in the nfl draft you're going to a team
that has really earned the first pick in
the nfl draft there are going to be some
holes there there was a reason the colts
were picking number one that year
there's a reason the bengals are picking
number one
this year i will say this though peyton
manning walked into a team that had
marvin harrison and marshall faulk for
crying out loud so the deck was slightly
better stacked although the bengals have
joe mixon and aj green i'll take marvin
harrison marshall falk over aj green and
joe mixon chris
yes i mean me too but you know aj green
and joe mixon is not a bad second you
know and then you know i do i think it's
you know curious that joe burrow you
know calls peyton manning i mean yes
that's the smart thing to do we've seen
nothing but really smart and perfection
and professionalism
from joe burrow since he's taken over as
the lsu quarterback and ever since he
got thrusted in the spotlight as the
best college player in football last
year and mike you know i said it you
know the guy that he really reminds me
of is peyton manning you know his style
of play the way he processes defenses
how quickly he can go through reads and
flip the side of the field and then
re-diagnose that side of the field and
make another you know proper decision
and accurate throw with the football
it's all just top-notch let alone like
those plays mike you see there he's got
the little backyard feel to him oh
scrambled to the right 40-yard bomb on
the run right on the money i mean to me
he really has a similar style to manny
he's just the new age version a little
more athletic than payton maybe not
quite as big but extremely accurate
extremely smart his arm is real good
it's not gonna wow you like brett favre
or elway or rogers but it's really good
and uh man i just i would be shocked
cincinnati's taking him number one we
can just move on to pick we really can
move on to pick number three because
washington's taking chase young they
better make that quick on thursday night
meanwhile for those of you keeping score
at home when it comes to chris sims
versus the english language thrusted is
an accepted past tense for thrust
although it is rarely used in most cases
thrust in the past tense of thrust not
thrust but you're okay on this one
just in case just in case if anybody
thinks i actually give a damn whether i
use that correctly
they should
they should check themselves because i
don't give a damn
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports